now why would you believe a guy with a
history replete with lies dishonesty and
contradictions
we'll find out Tuesday when disgraced
former FBI director james comey 'he's
booked a higher loyalty truth lies and
leadership hits the stands truth lies
and leadership really talk about an
oxymoron Jim you're the ultimate liar
you lied on multiple occasions to
multiple people including Congress under
oath and that's a crime truth you refuse
to follow the law causing both
Republicans and Democrats to call for
your head and leadership you violated
the rules of your own agency by leaking
classified information to a friend to
leak to the New York Times you went
along with Loretta Lynch's false
narrative that Hilary's case was a
matter not an investigation and folks
get ready for a knife fight between Jim
Comey and Loretta Lynch on both that as
well as that tarmac charade Jim you've
repeatedly proven your inability to run
the FBI in a non-political way you've
stayed silent as the New York Times
retracted the story that Hillary's FBI
review was a security referral and not a
criminal referral as if the FBI is a
security company installing locks in
people's you say the president is
unethical while you turned a
well-respected agency into a haven of
organized criminal conspirators at the
top echelon your book Jim isn't about
leadership it's about butt-kissing like
when you were struck by the way Barack
Obama could see and evaluate a variety
of angles and complicated issues his
insight and ability to connect with an
audience yeah right Jim
Barack's really bright like when he
bragged about traveling to all 57 states
the guys running for president
he thinks there were 57 states and the
person you most admired in government
James clapper another outrageous liar
who swore under oath before Congress
that the NSA doesn't surveil Americans
then in an obvious display of lying
shifts his eyes in his body and says
well not wittingly Jim your book is as
petty unprofessional and illegitimate as
a stormy Daniels resume real now you
actually talk about the size of the
president's hands whether he used
tanning goggles in a tanning booth and
whether his hair is real FBI agents Jim
behind your back called you Cardinal
Comey but Jim you're not
holier-than-thou you're nothing more
than a political operative orchestrating
your own effort to make yourself the
center of America's moral compass
beginning with your two-step the one
that you and your friend Bob Muller then
had bi director who at your request
brought in the FBI agents to make sure
the Secret Service didn't block your
dramatic entrance in John asks cross
hospital bedside claiming that you were
willing to resign if the Attorney
General didn't follow your suggestion
but enough about you let's read the
books EPS excerpts now you claim the
president sitting at his desk in the
Oval Office was a king sitting on a
throne a king because there was a block
of wood between you and the president
and Jim did you ever be appear before a
judge
Jim you say the president was concerned
when you presented him with your fake
dossier alleging the President had
prostitutes peeing on him in Moscow and
then you tear Milania down how could
your wife think is a 1% chance you're
with prostitutes peeing on each other in
Moscow I'm a flawed human being but
there's literally zero chance that my
wife would think that was true I'm happy
for you Jim that your wife Patrice would
never think that of you
but then again Jim Patrice was never
actually presented with a fake dossier
by the director of the FBI who
parenthetically knew it wasn't true and
the president didn't just bring it up in
conversation you're the one who went to
talk to the President to inform him of
what you knew at the time was not
verified the whole thing was a charade
and when you were asked by step'
innopolis but did he have a right to
know that they'd have been financed by
his political opponents I don't know the
answer to that you don't know the answer
and of course just they hit the
president a little more and to get a
great headline you say this but I don't
know whether the current president
knighted States with his prostitutes
peeing on each other in Moscow in 2013
it's possible but I don't know Jim it's
possible and it's possible Martians were
in that room peeing on the prostitutes
too
maybe we should start a new
investigation our Martians colluding
with the prostitutes to make the
president look bad and when you ridicule
the president asking you whether he
looked like a guy who needed hookers
your answer aye sir I'm not saying that
we credit this not saying we believe it
but Jim you don't credit it you don't
believe it Jim you're a liar
this is the dossier that you presented
to a FISA Court judge and you admit you
told the president you couldn't credit
it when you said you couldn't believe it
and yet you seek a warrant from a judge
based on this fake dossier were you
lying before the judge or were you lying
in the book and while we're at it Jim
your explanation for announcing
Hillary's renewed investigation you
claimed it was because you told Congress
that if new information were to come to
light that would tell them Jim you could
have told them without a televised press
conference you could have called two men
into
with you and told them and Jim I thought
politics didn't enter any of your
decisions and yet you have the hots vada
claimed that none of your decisions were
based on politics but from your own book
you say quote when I thought she was
going to win meaning Hillary I didn't
want a tainted president but you know
what Jim
neither claim is true everyone in law
enforcement knows that you reopen the
Hillary Clinton case because the NYPD
and the New York FBI field office were
going to out you for protecting her yet
again by not reopening the case anyway
the ultimate proof that you didn't want
to indict her is not only the
exoneration memo you wrote six weeks and
17 witnesses before she was interviewed
but knowing that she had classified
information on her emails which you
swore under oath was true not asking her
this question Hillary did you have
classified information on your emails if
she said yes that's a crime if she said
no she lied and that's a crime and by
the way we'll talk for a minute about
your career at the FBI how many cases
did you screw up the Boston bombers the
Fort Hood massacre the Oland or pulse
nightclub shooting the San Bernardino
Massacre the attacks of 9/11 you were
involved in all of them come on Jim your
self-serving statements about a crying
Chuck Schumer thanking you for your
Hillary decision and you on the verge of
tears after Obama told you how great you
are
come on you're self-absorbed memo
memoirs all about you you're a pompous
egotistical patronizing condescending
holier-than-thou political operative
trying to redeem your reputation and
cash in on lies which is the opposite of
truth and leadership your book is about
a higher loyalty to none other than you
yourself and that's my open